Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
There are two main branches of efficient smoke
and fluid simulator programs: Eulerian and
Lagrangian techniques.
Before we dive into what these terms mean,
I'd like to note that we have closed captions
available for this series that you can turn
on by clicking the cc button at the bottom
of the player.
With that out of the way, the Eulerian technique
means that we have a fixed grid, and the measurement
happens in the gridpoints only. We have no
idea what happens between these gridpoints.
It may sound counterintuitive at first because
it has no notion of particles at all.
With the Lagrangian technique, we have particles
that move around in space, and we measure
important quantities like velocity and pressure
with these particles.
In short, Eulerian - grids, Lagrangian - particles.
Normally, the problem with Eulerian simulations
is that we don't know what exactly happens
between the gridpoints, causing information
to disappear in these regions. To alleviate
this, they are usually combined with Lagrangian
techniques, because if we also track all these
particles individually, we cannot lose any
of them. The drawback is, of course, that
we need to simulate millions of particles,
which will take at least a few minutes for
every frame we wish to compute.
By formulating his famous equation, the Austrian
physicist Erwin Schrödinger won the Nobel
prize in 1933. In case you're wondering, yes,
this is the guy who forgot to feed his cat.
There is two important things you should know
about the Schrödinger equation: one is that
it is used to describe how subatomic particles
behave in time, and two, it has absolutely
nothing to do with large-scale fluid simulations
whatsoever.
The point of this work is to reformulate Schödinger's
equation in a way that it tracks the density
and the velocity of the fluid in time. This
way, it can be integrated in a purely grid-based,
Eulerian fluid simulator, and we don't need
to track all these individual particles one
by one, but we can still keep these fine,
small-scale details in a way that rivals Lagrangian
simulations, but without the huge additional
costs.
So, the idea is absolutely bonkers, just the
thought of doing this sounds so outlandish
to me. And it works!
Obstacles are also supported by this technique.
Many questions still remain, such as how to
mix different fluid interfaces together, how
to model the forces between them. I do not
have the prescience to see the limits of the
approach, but I am quite convinced that this
direction holds a lot of promise for the future.
I cannot wait to play with the code and see
some followup works on this! As always, everything
is linked in the video description box.
The paper is not only absolutely beautifully
written, but it is also a really fun paper
to read. As I read it, I really loved how
a jolt of epiphany ran through me. It is a
fantastic feeling when a lightbulb lights
up in my mind as I suddenly get to understand
something. I think it is the scientist's equivalent
of obtaining englightenment. May it happen
to you Fellow Scholars often during your journeys!
And I get to spend quite a bit of time every
day reading fine works like this. It's a good
life.
I'd like to give a quick shoutout to this
really cool website called Short Science,
which is a collection of crowdsourced short
summaries for scientific papers. Really cool
stuff, make sure to have a look!
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!